- Americanos moyens viens tout de suite
frère tu es encore prêt Oh quel mec comment
vas-tu si vite ton premier baiser non
j'attends j'ai compris
Kevin tu es un homme bon
[Musique]
ce quartier est préoccupé par le
meurtre d'un jeune de 17 ans  ont-ils
une idée de qui l'a fait, quel que soit le gang dans lequel il se trouve
et ils viennent de l'embaucher, pourquoi
tout le monde dit que c'est un truc de gang, la
police cherche toujours des pistes dans le cas
de Kevin Broadus, un élève du lycée Kennedy tué,
vous pouvez voir à l'intérieur de nos
émotions  sont crus tout le monde dans cette pièce
a mal kevin Broadus n'était pas dans un
jeu nous apprécions votre temps,
veuillez envoyer la prochaine personne dans mon ami
vient d'être tué vous ne pouvez pas vous attendre à ce que
je reste assis et ne rien faire à ce sujet
la police  ont déjà pris leur
décision, ils vont écrire tout
cela car un gang tuant quelqu'un
doit faire quelque chose pourquoi êtes-vous si
intéressé cela n'a tout simplement pas vraiment
de sens pourquoi quelqu'un tuerait à nouveau je
ne sais pas pourquoi mais  peut-être que riche est parti  na
dois apprendre à vivre avec ça
tu arrêtes ces bêtises c'est une
enquête pour meurtre tu ne sais pas ce qui pourrait
arriver il est mêlé à des
gens lourds ils sont dangereux
dit tu as quelque chose pour moi
tu vois où nous sommes assez
mon  ma femme a dû trouver ça
es-tu un revendeur non tu fournissais
mon fils
je m'inquiète pour toi bien si tu venais
ici pour essayer de me dissuader de faire
quelque chose de fou
ne t'embête pas nous ne pouvons plus en faire partie
maintenant  Je n'ai rien à perdre
ne sois pas stupide ne va pas vers
toi